[Music]
evelyn can you tell us what life was
like
before this all started
yes okay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
caused by war
driven by fear
this is an exodus
the biggest movement of people since
world war ii
since russia's invasion of ukraine
millions have come to live
it's close to the polish border
far from the bitter fighting further
east
in searching for safety families have
been ripped apart
but escapes from cities under fire are
moments of utter relief
everyone that has come here has made
life-changing decisions in minutes
what to bring where to go should they
stay in ukraine or become a refugee
but the initial choice to leave a home
under fire is simple if stark
it's flee
or die
so
it was a terrifying escape
my home is journey
i love chernobyl
but i must leave
my
my town
it's
terrible
it's terrible
i went home
you want to go home
[Music]
yes
dina was just finishing primary school
now their home looks like this
is
[Applause]
the family have left nearly everything
behind
including evelina's fiancee he's now
fighting in the ukrainian army along
with her brother
yep
foreign that means here her and dina are
alone
but they've come prepared
tonight in a city full of strangers they
need to find somewhere to stay
this bus will take them to a temporary
hostel
they don't know where it is or how long
they'll have to be there
but if people thought being in the west
ensured safety they were wrong
a russian missile is hit a mile from the
center of lev
it's a targeted attack on an oil depot
but in what's meant to be a place of
sanctuary it's frightening to see
and a reminder
this is no place for the vulnerable
a delicate operation is happening inside
levi's children's hospital
it's trying to protect patients taping
windows to stop them shattering
but doctors know it's not enough
what they are planning will be nearly
impossible to execute
a rapid group evacuation from the cancer
ward
we are responsible for this kids yes
this is
400 kids so we're responsible for them
so yes of course a lot of pressure yes
there is oppression
it's an immense task taking sick
children through a war zone across
international borders
a clinic in poland has been organised as
a first stop but beyond that families
still don't know what country they'll
end up in
alina is seven and has been in and out
of hospital for months
treated for a malignant
foreign
but they have to move fast war has
affected drug supplies and care is
constantly disrupted
[Music]
for the third time today the sick
scramble to the basement
down into what must be one of the
strangest air raid shelters in ukraine
this hospital was built during the
soviet era
families are sheltering in underground
saunas
and a swimming pool
spaces built as luxuries for soviet
leaders now protect ukrainians from
russian bombs
no seriously
it's an anxious weight
in the southern city of mariopol people
in a shelter were killed when walls
collapsed on them during shelling
it's a horrific story
one people here can't forget
[Music]
[Music]
there are no more guarantees
[Music]
when even rural western towns have been
hit
everywhere feels tense
[Music]
on the second day of war anna chachelle
niska decided to escape her home in kiev
with her children elena
and maxine
[Music]
they headed west
cramming themselves into the back seat
of a car
um
[Laughter]
as they were driving the family were
caught in fighting
foreign
[Music]
my
anna and elena were both in hospital
when maxine was buried
[Music]
do you think
you will stay in ukraine or do you think
you will
have to leave
it
there is no answer
war is tearing families apart
and for some to seek safety means there
will be goodbyes
and a journey that will make them
refugees
but could save their lives
it's the day of the medical convoy
doctors will try and evacuate 27 sick
children not just out of libid hospital
but out of ukraine
you feel afraid
why why are you feeling so frightened
[Music]
families will leave not knowing their
destination
doctors are still trying to link them up
with hospitals which could be anywhere
in the world
[Music]
mothers female relatives and younger
siblings will go
but men of fighting age cannot leave
ukraine
fathers have to stay
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
these are precious last moments
it's heartbreaking
[Music]
but possibly life-saving
[Music]
finally everyone's ready
the convoy moves fast
it has to
the children's conditions can change
rapidly
and there have been missile strikes
nearby
i don't want to
make you anxious but you know we are in
a war zone
there is nearby the polygon when the
missiles kill a lot of people so we have
to think about it and we have to go very
quickly so we have the police we have
our polish diplomats which open our ways
because we cannot be here in a gem
because if we will be here everything
may happen okay so right now we are
close to the border so we have to pay
attention on this operation
we've just come up to the polish border
and for the last hour or so people have
been chatting with each other feeding
their babies making sure that their
children are comfortable but as we've
got here
it's a bit more anxious people know that
they might be crossing this border and
they don't know when they're going to be
crossing back
the reality of what lies ahead suddenly
hits
lots of crying right now
crosstalk
but right now there's a problem
the coach driver is male and ukrainian
even though he'll return today he's not
being allowed over the border
it stalled the convoy
urgent calls are made but in the delay a
child in one of the ambulances
deteriorates
everyone's tense
has just finished his third round of
chemotherapy
her husband left at home anna's
traveling with her three children
including three-month-old victoria
mama my mother your mother's hair yeah
what would we do without that should be
our beloved mama
it's a movement of meters
that makes them all refugees
since the start of this war millions of
people have left ukraine
but even more have fought to stay
we met evelina and her daughter dina in
lev
they'd escaped their home in bombed out
chernahiv
and have ended up here
a school that's been shut and used for
shelter
okay okay we
sleep the physics classroom okay
hello
her fiance dima and his mother are still
she's told that roots in and out have
been shelled that if they hadn't left
they would now be trapped
any little thing from home feels even
more precious
hello
[Music]
how are you
you okay
there are now shelters like this one
across ukraine
days are filled with games on phones
[Music]
is here as best she can
but all she wants is to go home
[Music]
yes
the life will never be normal again
i
the speed with which life has changed
for so many feels surreal
several of the families we followed over
the border to poland are now in italy
being treated in a hospital and staying
at this hostel
moments from the coliseum
how are you yes bravo
the families can stay here rent-free
after so much travel and change it's a
moment to pause and reflect
but in a war where so many need help not
everyone has got where they wanted to be
oksana so desperate to be in italy and
near her sister is still waiting in the
clinic in poland
do you feel quite alone at the moment
next time
[Music]
waiting is really all they can do
this wall has stripped people of
certainty
of control
but not love
[Music]
not the need to protect
and when so much has been taken
dreams are clung onto
hopes
[Music]
and you're meant to be getting married
in a few weeks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you